good afternoon everybody my name is Mark
Baum Ford I'm the director for the Yale
sustainable food program it's my great
honor and pleasure to be seeing you all
here this afternoon and to welcome our
very special guests here I wanted to
start with a very short little story
that I've actually heard so many times
in so many different versions that I'm
not actually sure how much of it is true
but I'll tell it to you anyways it's 15
years ago just to set the stage 15 years
ago was actually a very very different
world especially the world of food this
was before Michael Pollan it was before
the Omnivore's Dilemma it was before the
White House garden and Michelle Obama's
let's move campaign there were 6,000 new
farmers markets that had yet to come to
the US and our world was bereft of more
than 5,000 edible education school yard
sites around the world it was a time
when many of the things that today we
consider mainstream many of the best
things we consider mainstream were
hiding in the margins waiting perhaps
for a push 15 years ago the term
institutional food referred to something
utilitarian and regrettable it was the
punchline of many kind of sad defeatist
jokes eating in such an establishment as
an institution was kind of more akin to
filling up the tank of your car with gas
it was something that you kind of had to
do as a necessary but unfortunate can
inconvenience so picture in one of these
sad cafeterias right here 15 years ago
you have a freshman and she is waiting
with her mother during parents visiting
weekend and whispers into her mother's
ear with something which is partially
appley partially a command promise me
you won't say anything about the food
this whispered plea it was particularly
urgent because the mother in question
had superpowers this mother was Alice
Waters which totally changed everything
about the story because Alice Waters has
the power to change everything about the
story we just came from my college
seminar approaches to sustainable food
and agriculture the registration is
capped at 18 students which means that I
have to say no to 19 out of every 20
students who apply for it this has
happened every year for the three years
that I've been offering it this doesn't
happen by accident the fact that
students are interested in food and
agricultural topics at the core of their
study and every single discipline in
this university this does not happen by
accident it needed a spark a spark to
get it going for Yale and for so many
places in the country Alice has provided
this spark she's done this by being
fearless she's done it by having a
vision that is always just a few decades
ahead of its time but for her speaking
out or not for her speaking out there
would be no real sustainable food
program without her strength of
conviction gardens and farms would not
be sprouting up to the point where they
are actually de rigueur on college
campuses the question is no longer does
your college have a farm but how good is
your college farm our medical students
and our nursing students they wouldn't
be learning nutrition at West's campuses
farm and in its kitchen our students
might still experience trepidation at
the thought of a dining hall rather than
the anticipation associated with today's
offerings which are fresh seasonal plant
forward and all conceived by a certified
master chef but most importantly our
students and our graduates would not be
around the world using food as an avenue
for social transformation this is a lot
to ascribe to one person but if you
spend some time in her company you'll
lose your skepticism Alice's power to
create change is something that can be
fairly described as a superpower at Yale
were not alone in recognizing Alice's
accomplishments it's typical to list
these all in an introduction to a guest
speaker
but we would be here for a very very
long time in the case of Alice I'll pick
out three she was made a companion of
the Legion of Honor in France she was
given an honorary Doctorate at Princeton
University and President Obama recently
awarded her the National Humanities
medal so in thanks for her vision her
fearlessness and her recognition that
good food was really just the beginning
it's my great pleasure to welcome Alice
Waters
but a wonderful but a wonderful
introduction really now I have to live
up to that there's expectations and I'm
really I'm really so so pleased to be
here at Yale again and it's particularly
meaningful for me to be here at this
moment in time and to make this
presentation to you the recent
demonstrations and protests on the
campus around the issues of race and
equality have really touched me
it reminds me of the Free Speech
Movement back in Berkeley in the 60s
that time was very important to me and
it formed much of my politics and my
activism then like now as many of you
know students gathered together found
their voice took their grievances to the
University offices and out into the
street and to the nation at large it was
a profound moment and it showed me the
power of speaking out the modern food
movement was born during the Free Speech
Movement
besides civil rights and ending the war
that was a time we were also talking up
publicly about organic agriculture and
the dangers of industrialized food and
we also demanded fair wages and safe
safe working conditions for the farm
workers all of these issues civil rights
non-violence access to safe and
nourishing food for everyone they're all
about equality all these issues are
about dignity and respect
I'm really always interested in what's
happening here at Yale because it really
was one of the first universities to
take edible education seriously and as
you pointed out so well and the
introduction about how I came to start
this project and I it was true my my
daughter cringed when I brought up the
idea of helping to change the food at
Yale to the president when we were
meeting him for the very first time but
the end of the story was that he said oh
come and talk to me in my office and
next week and so I stayed a little bit
longer and I went to his office and he
said well when I when you think about
starting this and I said well you know
and I said I'm talking about the whole
university changing the food at the
whole university he's and he said well I
thought you wanted to come and cook at
my house and I I think there's I mean
who knows but he said right away you
need to come and talk to the CFO of the
university so his name was Bob colfra
and I went and I talked to him and I
told him things that I tell everybody
that the university should start buying
organic food in season all of it that it
should recreate or create relationships
with local farmers and ranchers to
procure that food and it should rethink
its environmental practices in and
around cafeterias and it should include
students more in the preparing and the
sharing of what they ate and to my
surprise Bob said I want to do this
I understand this my family had a farm
but their land was bought and developed
and I really do get the importance of
everything that you're saying from the
benefits for our students to the
well-being the well-being of the
environment and the in cultural
enhancements so that's how it began and
I I think the president Levin was a
little surprised and maybe he was
impressed I think he was how quickly we
were able to get money and make
something happen and starts something we
did we hired I dare say a student from
Harvard Josh for tell and he along with
students from Yale helped to start that
garden which is flourishing right up the
hill I went to see it yesterday and even
in the middle of winter you could
imagine what was growing inside those
hot houses and I just saw the fireplace
waiting to be used and the tables where
the students could gather and and I I
always find it great to come back to
Burke to college because it was the
first college that expressed interest
and and when I went to meet John who was
the master of the college I noticed a
poster in his kitchen from Chez Panisse
and John claimed he just didn't put it
up that day and I guess I chose to
believe him we ultimately couldn't of
course provide all the food from for
Berkeley's cafeteria from that tiny
garden we needed a really of working
farm to do that but we did figure other
sustainable ways of getting food to
students ways that supported a real
network of ranchers and farmers that are
in this this area
even at times people tried to get a
duplicate there there there what do you
call the card for eating their card ID
so that they could get into Berkeley
College I love that no it was very
gratifying to to see the Yale
sustainable food project program they
call it now take off and I'm here really
to cheerlead for it for all the reasons
you can imagine now I know it's hard to
sustain these practices and principles
especially when you have to pass them
from one class to another from one food
service director to another but I just
want to say that it's so important to
write them down it's one of the reasons
that I want to write this kind of
manifesto of sorts a clear plan of
action so that everybody can understand
so that the achievements the
accomplishments and lessons from one
group can be understanding to it by
another group and it's why I focused so
intently on a food policy for the City
of Berkeley in the end it really has
helped us with the edible school year
yard project in in the whole school
system because we had that food policy
established by the City of Berkeley and
it's very very important to write down
these principles so I'm going to today
give you a little sense of this
manifesto that I am writing and it's
been a speech that I've been giving for
a little while and every time I give it
I learned something so I hope you will
give me your feedback it's very
important so here goes I think I think
we can all agree that there are very
serious issues in this world today
besides discrimination
there's obesity diabetes addictions
depressions pesticide use GMO food the
economy land use water youth fair wages
for workers violence terrorism poverty
and childhood hunger the overarching
fear of climate change and the list goes
on it's overwhelming
in my opinion all of these dreadful
issues we face and they are dreadful
each and every one of them all of these
issues are really outgrowth of a bigger
more encompassing thing there are
consequences of a much more fundamental
and deeply rooted condition one that
provides the soil if you will for all of
these other issues to grow out of and by
not addressing this deeper larger more
pervasive condition what we're trying to
do with all of our well-intentioned
attempts to solve these surface problems
is merely treat the symptoms of a
disease without dealing with the root
causes of the disease itself unless we
deal with the deeper more insidious
systemic condition all of our other
problems won't ever really go away
they'll come back like weeds that you've
pulled from your garden one year and
they return the next so what is this
deep systemic condition that underlies
all of our problems the author Eric
Schlosser one of my personal heroes and
one of the great muckrakers of our time
has pointed out that in the United
States we live in Fast Food Nation fast
food is sad to say the dominant way
people eat in this country and I'm sure
I don't need to tell any of you this
but what I'm not sure you might realize
and it's something that I've only come
to recognize in the last decade or so is
that fast food is not only about food
it's much bigger than that way bigger
it's about culture fast food not only
affects our diets but it affects our
rituals our traditions our behaviors our
relationships expressions laws ways of
working systems and ways of doing things
the effective fast food doesn't just
happen at chain restaurants along
freeways or in malls or in airports or
in school cafeterias it permeates
everything from the way that we look at
the world to how we operate in it to how
we see ourselves how we express
ourselves the ways we do business to our
architecture our entertainment our
journalism how we treat each other how
we interact with each other or in many
cases these days don't interact with
each other the clothes we wear what we
buy and sell our parks our schools our
politics and the list goes on fast food
culture has become the dominant culture
in the United States and I've worried
it's becoming the dominant culture of
this world this is the bigger condition
the soil if you will that all these
problems grow out of fast food culture
you see like all cultures fast food
culture has its own set of values which
I call fast food values and these values
saturated our ways of thinking and
inform our ways of doing things so
thoroughly that I don't think we see
them anymore they're just part of our
make up part of the land
cape part of our biology at this point I
fear part of our daily lives
and they completely degrade our human
experience an example of a fast-food
culture value is uniformity the idea
that everything should be the same
wherever you go you know the pizzas that
you get here in New Haven should be
exactly like the one you might get in
Tokyo the t-shirt you buy in Brooklyn
should match exactly the one you buy in
Sydney or there's something wrong with
it
we take this value for granted we
actually like it it thrills us it's
modern
it comforts us but like all fast-food
values uniformity masks deeper darker
issues in this case I would say the
pressure to conform the loss of
individuality or the respect for
uniqueness even prejudice and control
all eggs should look the same all houses
should look alike
everyone should behave in a certain way
or there's something wrong with them
speed now there's another fast food
value things should happen really fast
the faster the better I have to confess
this is me you water it you should get
it you want it you should have it right
that no waiting
the faster something's done the better
when you live like this I fear that you
not only do our expectations become
warps but we also become easily
distractible we lose our sense that the
best things take time
like growing food or cooking or learning
or growing a business or getting to know
someone these days if there's not
instant gratification we get frustrated
there
no maturity no time for reflection no
patience the faster it's delivered the
faster it's communicated the more
valuable time is money
how many cows can you slaughter in the
slaughterhouse in a day how many
patients can you see in an hour how fast
can you eat your school lunch
availability that's another fast food
value the idea that we should be able to
get whatever we want wherever we are
whenever we want it 24/7 you should be
able to get it a tomato in Switzerland
in the middle of winter you should be
able to get a V on water and Nairobi you
should be able to get a peach in New
England in February you should be able
to have cell phone coverage wherever you
go I know I felt victim to that one the
twisted idea of availability to me not
only spoils people but causes them to
lose track of where they are in time and
space
seasons stop mattering what's indigenous
to certain places becomes unclear maybe
even irrelevant there's always a feeling
oh there's something better over there
local culture and specialness of what's
happening here and now is less important
than the very big homogenized fast food
get anything you want global reality or
in my view unreality being present to
what's going on around you is devalued I
mean just look at how many people these
days are looking at their smartphones
while they walk down the street I'm not
sure they even are aware of where they
are yes and how many are checking your
cell phones right now well just hold on
a minute let me get mine
I must've left it on my seat how can I
be away from it for a minute
cheapness cheapness this one drives me
crazy in the United States there's a
complete mixing up of the idea of
affordability with cheapness there's a
deep feeling that value is equated with
bargains no one understands the real
costs of things anymore because one no
one tells them and two everything is
artificially priced supported by
subsidies and corporate sleight of hand
and credit because I believe in paying
people for the true cost of their their
work and their products people say that
I'm artificially driving up the prices
of food I say that it's the discounted
prices that are artificial and I feel
like I have a responsibility to pay the
true costs of things if I can there was
a great up head in the New York Times
last year you might have read it it was
about a small organic farmer described
quite eloquently how he and many other
farmers he knew need to work two or
three jobs just to keep their farms
going and he said it was a myth that
small farms like his were making it well
I don't think this would be a myth if
the farmers were paid appropriately for
the beautiful food they provide to all
of us the truth is and it's something
that we all need to learn things can be
affordable but they can never be cheap
when I hear somebody say I got a cheaper
over there
I just feel instinctively that somebody
somewhere is being sold out you cannot
not pay for something here
without someone over there not getting
what they deserve and you cannot not pay
for something here and not expect to
have other problems in your life over
there like with the environment or with
your health or international relations
or human rights for that matter in the
end all of these deals cost us much much
more money all of us and I think we know
deep down we just don't want to face it
there are many other fast-food values
I'm sure you can identify some for
yourself like I say they're invisible at
first but once you start to notice them
you see them everywhere it's quite
shocking work is drudgery that's what
many of us accept this is natural I
assure you
work doesn't have to be drudgery unless
you're in a system created and supported
by a fast-food culture work in my mind
though at times difficult should
actually provide a sense of value and
accomplishment a sense of purpose and
satisfaction a certain kind of pleasure
but fast food culture by its very nature
for it's very survival strips work of
all these possibilities it makes us
believe that work should be something
degrading and meaningless hollow a job
just something to get through to make
money and fast food culture leads us of
our humanity as we work within it and
sadly as we work inside fast food
culture we inadvertently strengthen it
and trap ourselves inside it and what
really gets to me is after convincing us
the
burkas treachery fast food culture then
provides us with the so-called pleasures
to fill the emptiness that dissatisfied
work life has left inside us pleasures
like well fast food for one and video
games in TV and arrows and Facebook and
alcohol and drugs and cruise ships and
things I call consumption vacations
where people just go and gorge
themselves to make themselves feel
better
and I've just seen some videos about the
Spring Breaks people are having pretty
shocking well basically the way I see it
is fast food culture separates work and
pleasure for us and then it profits from
the separation more is better
it's another fast-food value the more
you pile on the plate that happier
you'll be the more massive the store the
better the more apps you have the more
connected and fulfilled basically the
more you have or the more choices you're
offered the better now I find this
fast-food value so strange because to me
when I get too much stuff I I'm I have
too many choices and I get overwhelmed
and burdened by it there's no room for
discernment
there's just weight and volume at Chez
Panisse we used to be criticized so much
because we only had one menu but it was
the only way that I could simplify
things and guide people towards what I
wanted them to taste and to feel and to
know and now people actually look
forward to having only one meal so they
can focus on it and they can maybe taste
something that they've never tasted
before that surprises them or delights
them something they can save her and
remember well I heard I heard that there
was
a chain in England the same chain as in
this country and in England they were
serving have portions for the same price
that we served the large portion now I
don't know what the moral is exactly
except I don't think it's more it's
better as you know we have an obesity
epidemic in this country and I think
it's intimately connected with the idea
of more is better it's actually a
physical manifestation of that some fast
food values can be more abstract and
elusive like terminology for instance
and how it's used or misused and the
confusion around it I mean what does
organic mean these days natural for that
matter what is local mean Fairtrade
fresh it seems that these definitions of
terms have been hijacked and they seem
to fluctuate and have more to do with
marketing and presentation than with
attempts to clarify and inform and
what's scarier is how fast these terms
get hijacked in the field of food and my
work we find a term that works like
sustainable and it gets grabbed
immediately by the fast-food culture and
is used everywhere indiscriminately and
in no time at all the term becomes
cloudy and misleading if not meaningless
and there are many others such slippery
terms that I'm aware of how about
pesticide free or fda-approved how about
peace with honour college degree
behind the issue of terminology is the
issue of standards what standards are we
really using and where did they come
from
there seemed to be standards but they
don't mean anything or worse they reduce
standards like in the case of schools
sometimes manipulate their standards in
order to receive financial aid or food
companies who lobby to get chem
chemicals considered natural ingredients
in their products in other cases it
seems to me we're too willing to
compromise or change standards or
abandon them altogether we used to serve
filtered water at Chez Panisse mainly
because we found that but the government
considers safe we're not so sure about
and take the term grass-fed you can use
that term believe it or not if the
animals have only been grass-fed for two
weeks so in many cases it's kind of a
lie another fast food of value
dishonesty perhaps that's the biggest
one of all I saw a bumper sticker awhile
back and it said if we are what we eat
then I'm fast cheap and easy I don't
think I can say it any better than that
the reason these values are so important
to me is that values shape behavior so
if the culture around us is glamorizing
and promoting values that dehumanize us
then all of us naturally are going to
act in ways that dehumanize us it's
going to feel right to behave that way
in sync with the culture around us and
if we act in those ways that dehumanize
us all the problems have
is talking about at the beginning well
they can't help but occur they're
actually all problems of dehumanization
I really believe that I know this sounds
intense and it is intense but I think we
have to just face it and I recently saw
a great film about Cesar Chavez's life
and I was so struck well by many things
but one of the things that struck me was
how brave he was and his fellow
activists farmworkers were they saw
something wrong they felt the injustice
and they started to articulate it and
protest and they were met with such
massive resistance threats to their
livelihoods and lives but they stayed
strong they were committed to what they
believed in they marched across those
fields and they stood up for what was
morally right and look what happened the
birth of the modern farm worker movement
in this country and there's so much more
work to be done but Cesar Chavez and his
colleagues were really holding the line
and that's at such an important time and
it's a lesson I think for all of us it
shows that what's what's possible in in
in the face of seemingly overwhelming
odds in the face of societal structures
that seem impenetrable and are deeply
wrong so yes there's an antidote no
surprise slow food culture slow food
culture is not as flashy and as
aggressive as fast food culture but it's
just as enticing it's richer deeper
truly life-affirming
one with customs and practices
cultivated over centuries since the
beginning of civilization it's a culture
connected to nature one that organizes
itself instinctively around nature's
cycles and patterns and lessons and it's
a universal culture so to speak we've
just left it behind and slow food
culture like fast food culture has its
own set of values what I call no
surprise slow food values
well slow food values are affirmative
values they're civilized earthbound ones
we know them through them we aspire to
create and connect to life and culture
that is naturally nurturing and enticing
and creative and joyful and truly
sustainable but these values actually
guide us and and help us to have
meaningful pleasurable lives brightness
ripeness
is a slow food value the idea that there
is a particular moment when the essence
of something is at its prime at its
greatest expression with the most
vitality and power in it when something
is ripe whether it's a fruit or a
creative idea or a political movement it
means that it has reached its peak
performance level it's ingested all the
nutrients integrated and metabolized all
the resources and it's ready to flourish
naturally it's something if something's
not right it's not ready it's still a
little weak just a shadow of what it
could be but ripeness is a value that
means that there's a right time for
everything and it's important to discern
when that right time is cherries are
most vibrant in the spring
a couple is ready to get married at a
certain moment a time is ripe for
political change and I just want to say
that I think the time is ripe inner
connectedness is another slow food value
the realization that we're all connected
to each other and everything around us
it's a feeling of being supported by and
dependent on something bigger than
ourselves when you really think about
interconnection you want to take care of
things it's natural and naturally and
pleasurably it leads to responsibility
and empathy and to love and you make
sure that the water upstream is clean so
that the farmer downstream who's who's
growing those vegetables can be sure
that they're nourishing you make sure
that you pass when you pass something
through on social media that it's
beneficial to people not abusive or
cruel or the whole network is affected
there's no true environmentalism
I don't think without a cent a sense of
interconnectedness I mean personally you
know I've never understood how
environmentalists don't understand food
because for me once you eat with
intention you really eat with intention
you digest environmentalism that's what
you do you really digestion eating
connects you with everything on the
planet almost by definition so how
you're eating is how you're connecting
with the planet there are many slow food
values as there are
fast-food values in fact when you start
naming them there are art so many more
thankfully but we need to be careful
because fast-food values which are alien
to our being are foisted upon us from
the outside
starting in preschool with the help of
advertising or and indoctrination
they're everywhere they're on our
televisions along the freeways in the
airports on our cellphones in our homes
but thankfully slow food values are
intrinsic to us we're born with them
they're part of our biological makeup at
the core of our very essence and they've
just been covered up deadened by the
assault of a fast food culture around us
and they're just waiting to be awakened
and stimulate and stimulated it just
takes a tiny spark I mean it's like this
you know the smell of an apple pie
coming out of the oven it's like reading
a book to a child who's sitting on your
lap you know it's seeing somebody just
smile at you on the street I mean this
is what it feels like and they can be
they just are naturally awakened and
once they are they grow inside of you
and they make you feel alive and your
perspective naturally shifts and your
behavior begins to change and your
existence brightens it's like you know a
barren field that is pour water on it
and it just sucks that anything comes
back to life and I always say that it's
like falling in love that used to be
easy remember my journey at Chez Panisse
is a good example of how Awakening
slow-food values can change things and
I'm sorry really to use Chez Panisse in
the as an example but
it's the only one I really know when we
started back in 1971 we weren't really
trying to start a revolution
or maybe we were we were really trying
to what we were really trying to do was
recreate the life that I'd experienced
in France as a student and that's how I
lucked out because I went to France and
at that time and this was in the early
60s France was a slow food culture
French people lived in a different way
moving in different rhythms focused on
different values so by trying to
recreate this European cafe life we at
Chez Panisse without really thinking
about it naturally expressed slow food
values in every decision we made and I'm
not talking about monumental decisions
here I'm talking about what kind of
chairs do you want to have in the dining
room ones that reflect craftsmanship and
beauty or plastic chairs that reflect
uniformity and mass production let's get
mismatched antique silverware at the
flea market which by the way was more
affordable and definitely more beautiful
instead of the industrial stainless
steel let's put freshly pick flowers on
the tables every day to remind us what
season we're in and let's really
consider the music we're playing in the
background so it brings people alive and
it doesn't drown out their conversations
and these very small personal decisions
we're like magic because like I said
they had slow food values already
embedded in them the same thing happened
in the kitchen we started cooking over
the fire and foraging for food in the
nearby hills and connecting with local
organic farmers pulling oysters out of
the water
that very day I didn't want any oysters
to sit in a refrigerator overnight and
if I didn't have to have walkins
I wouldn't have had them it's just the
way that they thought about food in
France and I wanted to do it like that
and these values changed us and the
world the more we practice them and the
cumulative effect was almost predestined
to be the broad culture that became Chez
Panisse and they are the things in my
mind that the customers actually
responded to they thought it was the
food and the decor and the service and
the politics but really it was the slow
food values embedded in everything that
was what people understood as unique and
this is why I so profoundly believe in
what I've been calling edible education
a slow food curriculum if you will that
begins when kids start school and
continues all the way through their
academic life I really feel like if we
turn students on to these kinds of
things that I'm talking about and
introduce them to the slow food values
when they're very young a miracle will
happen a new kind of living and learning
will become as Michael Pollan might say
second nature to all of them and through
them to all of us I don't know how many
of you know that I was a Montessori
teacher before I started shape eni's and
I saw firsthand how Maria Montessori
method of teaching worked
Montessori by the way liked and
understood food of course she was
Italian but she was so important to the
Italian culture by the way that they put
her on their money
she was on the thousand a thousand lira
note is that what it was the thousand
lira no yes well monasteries philosophy
is based on experiential education of
the senses see hear touch taste and
smell the senses are your pathways into
your mind and I believe and I've seen
that when children's senses are
stimulated and opened not only does
their learning improve but they also get
a clearer perspective on their world and
in the play and the place where they
live
it is a tried and true pedagogy that
first worked dramatically in the streets
of Rome and then in India with
children's whose senses had been closed
down to poverty and the harshness of
their lives and this is a really really
important point that I want to make
right here because I think today's kids
senses are closed down in similar ways
many by poverty and violence but all by
their unwitting indoctrination into a
fast food culture think about it every
single moment of their lives they're
confronted with it on TV on a computer
in their text books in their music on
their clothes in the advertising inside
school hallways with the corporate
branding of their favorite sports teams
and events with all the fast food
concessions that are around them on
every street corner
even in drugstores and parks it's
inescapable I saw in New York children
and strollers holding iPhones an edible
education is very different an inedible
education we ship
a student's focus by placing something
better in front of them as sense
oriented experience and by doing this
we're not
she was never about telling kids not to
do this don't eat that
don't do that she just made something
over there that was so irresistible that
the kids came over there and we do this
by placing food and food concerns not
only in the just in the middle of the
lunchroom program but at the center of
the curriculum of the whole school I
know it sounds unusual but eating is a
central part of all of our daily lives
and it has all of those slow food values
connected to it and so by integrating
food into a student's life in a
comprehensive way these values occur
naturally and democratically in each
school day all classes are affected and
energized because they're embedded in
real living evolving environments
project learning gets grounded not only
do kids start eating well but math
suddenly becomes a practical hands-on
taught class in the lab if you will of a
farm or a garden or a kitchen classroom
a foreign language is enhanced by the
translation of recipes or the
performance of music from other cultures
a biology class is illuminated by the
activity in the compost heap or by
studying and observing chickens and
insects in their national natural
habitats things like biodiversity and
interconnectedness and empathy are
experienced almost sub
consciously as if by osmosis just by
walking around a revitalized campus the
nature of the whole school starts to
change but the best thing on top of all
these others is that schools can create
sustainable support networks beyond
themselves like we did it's Chez Panisse
you can be doing this exactly at yeah
they can start buying organic food and
supplies directly from the farmers and
the retailers and send compass to the
city parks and back to the farms they
can transform their communities schools
can think about it 20% of the population
of this country is in school imagine
what would happen if we adopted
sustainable criteria for everything we
buy in the public school system not just
food but everything not only would we be
educating the next generation into a new
delicious way of eating and learning but
the schools themselves the universities
would become alternative economic
engines and they would bring that money
into their communities and that
relationship wouldn't it be fantastic if
schools supported our farms rather than
the other way around it would be it
would be more than great it would be
revolutionary can you imagine
schools supporting supported agriculture
so so this isn't just gardens in schools
that I'm talking about or a special
environmental awareness class we're not
just talking about improving food
service on campus we're talking about a
larger and more radical approach to
changing the face of all schools by
integrating these essential slow food
values into all aspects of scholarly
life I'm talking about changing the
pedagogy the philosophy behind what we
teach how we teach it and where we teach
it I'm talking about reimagining schools
from the ground up now you know I I have
seen this happen I over the last 20
years we started the Edible Schoolyard
in the school in Berkeley with a
thousand kids they spoke 22 different
languages at home but I want to tell you
that I was inspired by a project in the
San Francisco County Jail if you can
omit the director Catherine's knee
called me up and asked me if she had
vegetables that were grown by inmates at
the jail whether I would buy them and I
I didn't know what to say I said yes of
course I'll buy them and she said well
you have to come out to the trail and I
said no I'm not going to the jail she
said I'm not selling you the vegetables
unless you come to the jail and shows
she completely embarrassed me and I said
okay I go to the show
well she gathered everyone around and
she said I want you to tell Alice what
what what's happening here in this 7
acre garden and it's one guy stood up 22
years old been in and out of jail twice
and he said you know I shouldn't be
saying anything is this my first day in
the garden but it's the best day of my
life and I just oh my god if you can do
it in a in a chair you can do within the
school that this can be transformational
and that's the amazing thing
it turned out that at the end of that
project
Katherine Sneed she called him her
students didn't want to leave jail
because they wanted to stay in her
garden and she ended up having to open
up a halfway house garden outside the
jail and then they ended up growing
vegetables that they sold at the San
Francisco farmers market and then after
that they got jobs in the tree core and
they never went back to jail so that's
that's what we're trying to do is to
help these students uh before they drop
out of school and go to jail so that's
that's really that's really what this is
all about and I have to say that that we
started a project in Sacramento in a
high school and the idea behind it is to
have a student-run cafeteria where they
do every all parts of the curriculum in
the running of that business and that
has just begun with the mayor of
Sacramento and it's very exciting
because the students are so engaged they
showed me their first project I went up
there and they had they were our
architecture students and their project
that they chose to do was to build a
pizza oven in the garden and they did
all of the work of researching pizza
ovens around the world but ovens they
built a model pizza oven to present to
the client they had all of the reasons
for and against putting it in one place
or another and when we went that date
they had built it from the plans the
architectural plans they built the whole
thing and they lit the fire and it the
night that we do but what could be
better they were empowered by that
experience I mean I was just knocked out
but it's really beautiful now
lost my way in this hole in this whole
speech but I guess I want to really my
thesis my passion right now is that we
need to make school lunch free to every
child in this country free and
sustainable and I'm I'm looking to have
our president articulate that before he
leaves office that it's the plan if we
give every child the possibility of
coming around the table and eating
together in that place that we will have
succeeded in in bringing democracy back
to America and I'm I've been a big
believer in Gloria Steinem for a long
time and she said that public education
is our last truly democratic institution
and I know she's right everyone goes to
school or should and it's our common
place in our culture where we can reach
every child while they're opening open
and learning so I just want to tell you
one last thing that something amazing
happened at Chez Panisse last year at
the beginning it's a little bit over
that we had a dinner with all the
Chancellor's from the University of
California and the new president of the
University Janet Napolitano well I went
to the University of California and I I
know what a place it can be for change
and visionary global change and so I
wanted this Center to be very very
special and I always feel better when
I'm feeding people ideas so I decided
that I would spit roast these chickens
with black truffles in them and have
that sort of go
well they were eating their their crab
salad and for dessert
if they had a warm apple tart and some
honey ice cream and I set up these
tables two big long tables so everybody
could have a conversation with each
other and everything was going just as
it should have gone I had invited
Michael Pollan just for insurance but
but but the evening was magical and and
something amazing happened Janet
Napolitano stood up at the end of the
meal and she said I want to create a
compact for sustainability and and then
she sat down at the table she wrote it
out longhand and she said she wanted to
integrate food and agriculture into
every course of the university that she
wanted to change the buying practices to
support the farmers who were taking care
of the land and she wanted to have this
all accomplished by 2025 okay well she
wrote it all out she went around to
everybody in the room and had them
silent and I felt like you know I was
signing the Declaration of Independence
I really did I just was uh and it turned
out that it was Russian New Year a
Russian Christmas I should say it was on
the 8th of January last year and there
were two Russians there and we all went
upstairs in the cafe and we poured
champagne and they sang Russian songs
and I thought oh this is this is the
beginning of something extraordinary and
and it showed me again that in order to
make dramatic change
that we really have to articulate it we
have to say it out loud and when
something is hopeful and right and it's
done you know with integrity and beauty
everybody can feel it everybody can feel
it and it's it's it's like what Briard
Severn said almost two centuries ago
that the destiny of Nations depends on
how they nourish themselves that's what
he said and I never understood that
really I I thought well you you know
you're happy if you eat a lot of good
food I I didn't really get it and then
all of a sudden I realized that we are
what we eat
that when we eat fast food we digest
those values so so we have to really
think about this and be determined about
everything we eat eat with determination
and create this delicious revolution
thank you
thank you
I'm told that we actually have time for
a few questions there are microphones on
the side by the exit and in this center
aisle I believe five minutes is what we
have okay
ask ahead who's first
so I have a question about so beside
schools Randa is any fast company a fast
food company that it's gonna be old a
new company or a large or a small
company that really can implement slow
food movement into part of their
operation I still maintain their
scalability as a fast food company to
make a great successful in the business
but actually contributed people's health
that kind of value well that's a really
good question I there definitely it's a
place for fast slow food and I mean I'm
talking about where that food comes from
and I'm talking about including the way
that people are treated who work in that
business it's very very important that
we really consider it in the full
spectrum I just don't know I I want to
say that I don't know any huge fast-food
companies that are doing this the right
way and I think a lot has to do with
their needing to give the money to the
people who invest in the company I think
it's very very you know it's it's very
hard to manage a gigantic multinational
firm that's that's trying to do
something the right way yes this is an
amazing
school year menu and I understand that
you have a plan for the for August in
Washington Mall I was wondering if you
could share it with us oh goodness I do
think that I've thought for a while that
we need to have a big demonstration in
Washington around the hundredth
anniversary of the National Park Service
I don't know whether you know that on
the 25th of August it will its Founders
Day it was the day that John Muir had a
campfire with Teddy Roosevelt and they
created the the National Park Service so
I thought we could all go to Washington
and have some campfires and we were
going to call it this land is your land
and maybe we should get Patti Smith's to
sing it made me chew and buyers who
knows maybe all of them to sing it but
we really need to focus on our public
lands land that feeds us and I I think
it would demonstrate a hopefulness for
for this country if we went there to
them all now stay tuned to the head of
the National Park Service thinks it's a
good idea but we're in the process of
raising money so the next step we there
what you'll be they're all in it we need
you to come hello
I want to thank you yes I want to thank
you for your elegant inspiring words I'm
a volunteer board member for the local
so food chapter and this is wonderful to
hear but I'd like to extend an
invitation to the audience to join with
us and to work for your values we're at
slow food shoreline org so thank you
thank you I don't have any questions no
I appreciate what you do well I'm a vice
president of slow food international and
I'm always inspired when I hear Carlo
Petrini speak and I I think they're
going to be having a terror madre
demonstration in the streets of Torino
in September I I think it's so important
to know that there's something hopeful
globally going on
I had no idea when I met Carla Petrini
before that that I was part of that
movement without ever knowing I you know
with ever not being able to to have it
sort of something bigger than than what
we were doing at Berkeley and it's so
gratifying it so it's so inspiring for
me anybody else
question yes question as a college
student with a relatively low income and
I I really want to eat meat that's
grass-fed and local and organic and eat
vegetables that have come from a farm
that was grown near me but I can't
always afford that and I also I don't
even know where to find that grass-fed
organic meat around me in New Haven and
how should we how should we eat when we
can't eat the best well I think you can
eat the best I mean I I say this because
I think once you learn how to cook
simply that that you can make a very
very affordable meals for yourself now
Jose Andres I know he makes four or five
meals out of one chicken and and I
certainly make two or three out of one
chicken and and and knowing about how to
cook vegetables and grains and and
eating them exactly at that
in time I mean I I just think of how
many people a squash can feed and how
inexpensive it is but I think it's
really about balance learning how to
cook and I know there are many people in
this room and one right here next to me
who can direct you to exactly the right
stores to buy things from and or you can
be like my daughter did and when she was
in Berkeley years ago she just would go
over to the garden up there on the hill
and pick it menage with say you know we
don't have any deer in this garden we
just have Fanning here that growing
around being involved with a community
garden what a great way to to become
engaged and to eat something that's
really nourishing but my goal really in
my involvement with schools right now is
completely focused on what kind of food
we can serve and cafeterias in
institutions around the world and I keep
going to the Middle East keep going to
the place of spices of wholesome
vegetables and proteins of beans and
rice in India and we're finding that
food and I hope we can put it together
in a really good book soon thank you
you're welcome
I'd like to
thank all of you for joining us I'd like
to thank Alice and I just especially
like to thank Barbara and Benjamin
Zucker for helping Alice come here today
as our guest and for allowing us to have
inspiration a little guests for so long
through the Zeca fellowship it's
delightful thank you